this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
everyone hope you're doing well i've
thought about doing this type of video
for a long time on the channel now i
feel like it's it's time to just talk
about it this is a changing list at all
times i mean and this is my philosophy
about favorite books really the books
that we love and hold and cherish
they're kind of the ones that just
happen to pass us by at the right time
i'm always going to talk about books on
this channel always however if you do
like this kind of sit down talking about
books and movies and stuff like that
that i used to do that i haven't been
doing as much there's a second channel
now nadia and i are uh working on that
we made it's called woman carrying man
anyways the first book that i'm talking
about is
absalom absalom fun list right
this is required reading for many
college students in the united states
but i read this just out of pure fun
because i just hate joy this is a
notoriously difficult book uh so-called
you know it reportedly has like the
longest english language sentence ever
in a book i'm
there's some crazy avant-garde stuff out
there i'm sure that must have been
passed by now because this came out in
the 1930s this book is a wild well
southern gothic story about the worst
family
the worst family well it's about racism
above all else it is a an absolutely
disturbing sad sick violent very
melodramatic and moody book told in this
hysterical tone and i don't mean that in
like this derogatory way like it it has
this sustained hysteria that is just
magnified just this intensity at the
heart of it it's about thomas sutpen who
is basically this devil he is this being
of pure evil who is carving this empire
it's sort of a spiritual sequel to the
sound of the fury but you don't have to
read the sound and fury to get this book
sometimes it'll just turn into italics
you know people focus on faulkner as
like a stylist and stuff but he has some
of the best most engaging and
insane stories uh ever check this out if
you like a challenge something a little
lighter and uh quite dense is east of
eden now i have not read eastern in a
very long time i read this gosh probably
in high school and i absolutely loved it
i binged it and it was just beautiful i
am curious to see how i'd feel about it
today but i'm always going to regard it
as a favorite book just because nothing
really captured me like like this it's a
sweeping if if you're thinking of the
james dean movie do not because the
james dean movie is really only like the
last third of this book moving sad and
beautiful beautifully written totally
opposite from absalom absalom steinbeck
is very simplified sort of in the
hemingway school of writing worth a read
if you like big family dramas speaking
of uh challenging notorious books moby
dick i have a love-hate relationship
with this book but i'm always going to
love it and you know i haven't read it
is
i've read it like one and a half times
maybe two times i can't really remember
some of the the passages in this book
are just absolutely gorgeous and if
you're going to read this book i really
recommend getting this modern library
with the rockwell kent illustrations
because rockwell kent is uh this really
adds a lot to this book and there's so
many beautiful beautiful illustrations
this book is so honestly it's very ahead
of its time um i watched this great
review books by lanes
lanes i think that's what it's called
her channel go check it out but she had
this a wonderful review of talking about
the kind of um radical
perspectives in moby dick it's beautiful
like it's it's just it has some of the
most amazing writing the most amazing
like um monologues that you'll get and
it's really unconventional chapters will
just turn into a play there's a reason
why like everyone talks about it like i
i get that it's not like
something everyone wants to have on
their reading list definitely worth a
read and i think everyone should read it
once in their life next up and i think
this is kind of showing a pattern of
what i really love i'm not saying this
is a well-rounded list this is just my
personal taste but the next one i'm
including is one i read quite recently
called butcher's crossing by john
williams i've talked about this book a
number of times on the channel because
it is amazing hey it's being turned into
a movie with nicholas cage uh very soon
so it's basically about the brutality
and uh violence of the american west
uh similar themes to moby dick i would
say uh just this kind of breaking of
transcendentalism this kind of crushing
of this idealism of the american west in
this mythology that has been crafted and
it's it's a brutal brutal book that is
very just a very sober view of the
events that take place it's about man
versus nature and it's about man
destroying nature essentially same goes
with moby dick if you have an aversion
to like violence towards
animals just like moby dick is all about
the uh industrialized killing of whales
uh butcher's crossing is about the
industrialized killing of buffalo really
just these three guys killing buffalo
the ultimate villain is capitalism of
course but uh i can't reveal all of the
twists and turns it is an epic journey
of survival it is intense it is sad it
is beautifully written it's god it's a
it's a perfect book do yourself a favor
check it out it's becoming one of my
favorites next up is something
completely different and it is words of
radiance this is one that really brought
me back to my roots i think in terms of
the like the books i love fantasy i
think it's the best stormlight book it's
just a really magical wonderful
structure it has perfect build-up and
resolution it is a blockbuster it is a
it's a crowd pleaser it's totally unlike
these other books that i've been
mentioning i can't think of a book more
different from amsterdam absolutely
where absalom absalom is dense and
confusing and complex and layered this
is broad and epic masterful plotting it
just fires on every cylinder it's
beautiful i don't know how i'll feel
about it later on if there will be other
books that have like surpassed it in
terms of my view of fantasy but to me it
is my fav probably my favorite fantasy
book next up 2001 a space odyssey i
haven't read this book in a long time
but it's probably the book i've read
more than anything it was one of the
first like really major science fiction
books i read and although technically
people forget that technically it is a
novelization of the movie i think in the
book it says it's based on the
screenplay by arthur c clark and stanley
kubrick so arthur c clarke is what
happened was arthur c clarke and stanley
kubrick were writing the screenplay and
the book at the same time so there are
divergences um major ones but it works
as a novelization but it's also its own
thing and it's beautiful and arthur c
clarke i think did some of his mo his
best work um in this book where the
movie is kind of cold
and really open to interpretation the
novelization or i should just the novel
is strong authorial presence that is
just guiding you through this tale in a
very kind of in a very story-like manner
explores the mythology of this
amazing concept this book i'm a mega fan
like i literally not just this book but
i do love the sequels uh not so much
3001 but 2010 and 2061 i think are worth
a read one of my prized possessions is
is um my set this is one of the 2001
books i have but it's it's very close to
my heart and it always will be i think i
should do a reread of the series again i
don't know if people have any any
interest in that but i i would
definitely like to do that and see how
it holds up to me but regardless it's
always going to be one of if not my
favorite book but before i get to the
next book let's talk about skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skillshare i've been
really enjoying this and i bring this up
because it's really good the writer's
toolkit six steps to a successful
writing habit by simon van boy great way
to help you establish a writing habit if
you're the kind of person like me who
writes inconsistently got a lot from
this and i continue to get a lot from
this and i am starting to get a better
work life balance and writing habit
balance you can watch in bite size
videos it's curated specifically for
learning meaning there are no ads they
are always launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused skillshare now
offers classes in spanish french
portuguese and german the first thousand
people to click on the link in the
description get skillshare for free for
one month so check it out learn
something new and uh yeah on to the next
book now if you all know me you know
that no list uh like this would be uh
complete without ray bradbury the the
man who shares my birthday i love ray
bradbury's optimism uh the way he writes
it's extremely lyrical and some people
hate it it's very flowery over the top
when you need it you need it when you
need that nostalgia and that heart ray
bradbury is there there's like these two
sides to my favorite books i'm noticing
now because i just made this list really
dark exploring the darkest parts of
humanity and then this total opposite of
optimism and looking towards the future
i'll tell my therapist about it anyways
something wicked this way comes i don't
think it's perfect i think it has flaws
it just captures this this tone this
mood of fall you know this whole book
really explores what it means to be
young to be young at heart and uh
friendship it's so sincere it's hard to
look at it cynically some lines in this
book are just magnificent the way it's
written creepy too there's a lot of
creepy and dark darkness in this book
and i think that's what i love about
this is this contrast of youth and
friendship and danger and fear and
anxiety i will definitely be rereading
it probably this october next up is
something a little different and i was
debating what to include but i thought
no i want to talk about at least
something maybe others haven't
necessarily heard of the waterworks by
el doctoro this is like a detective
novel and it is written in a kind of
style that is reminiscent of edgrell and
poe and it's a very dark science fiction
novel really brutal but captivating it's
it's very unassuming it has this heart
and sadness to it that i really connect
with el doctoro wrote one of my other
favorite novels ragtime yeah but the
waterworks is i don't think enough
people are talking about the waterworks
if you love edgar allen poe that sort of
story this is a short book but a great
mystery check it out next up blood
meridian fun book i don't know if it's
one of my favorite books it's definitely
one of the most hard to classify books
and it really is like a spiritual
follow-up to moby dick one of the
scariest books really the last hundred
pages of this book are just suspense
nothing i've seen in movies or anything
i can compare to
the raw fear that the judge gives me
judge holden is this character in the
book who is described as being like
seven feet tall completely bald hairless
i think they say his face is like a baby
but like shaped like a baby whale or
like a dolphin like it's just he's got
these strange
massive features the the horrors that
existed that were done by the us
government it is a brutal disturbing
horrifying thing very in a lot of ways
like butcher's crossing messed up like
imagery that will haunt me to this day
but passages of amazing beauty like
paradise lost uh illusions uh are
everywhere i don't really know what to
think of it necessarily i think i want
to reread it for sure it's quite
repetitive if you stick through till
like the last 100 pages then you'll just
be sucked in right till the very end
probably the bloodiest book i've read
it's a book about violence there's a lot
of people who talk about this book so i
don't know what else to really say about
it except that it's
yeah it's a lot anyways to wrap up my
top ten i think this was ten the
complete calvin and hobbes i have this
set in the other room it's huge it
weighs like 50 pounds i i don't know
it's not like something i would
traditionally include i just feel like
if i'm talking about books that are
incredibly important to me and always
will be like why should i not include
calvin hobbs talk about one of the best
books ever amazing humor
life lessons artwork that is beautiful
imagination it's truly timeless that's
what i have to say about calvin and hops
it's great all right my voice is getting
kind of sore i got that off my chest
i'm sure i'm missing so many books that
i will as soon as i finish recording
will go why didn't i talk about this but
let me know like what's going on what
you want me to read i mean i'm open to
suggestions yeah again oh woman caring
man go check that out yeah thank you for
watching everyone bye
[Music]